how's the filming inside so let's go
take a look
[Music]
hi Josh so listen like working on this
film how much fun it's been great it's
at school it's the first project that
I've actually produced from like the
very beginning although through the
finished thing and it's been great we
have a really cool crew it's a lot of
fun I do a lot of bloopers accidentally
the very first shot of our likes little
small spoon area that we were doing on
this whole shoot yeah I couldn't get the
keys out of the car and it's just
interesting comedy so it's kind of crazy
because this started as a trailer that's
being turned into a movie yeah so what's
that kind of like going through that
process it's really cool it's really
interesting to see all the submissions
that come in from people because people
are asked to submit 60-second trailers
that they created and it was such a wide
variety it's really hard to choose a
final one we want to choose one that had
a lot of like feeling and kind of oak
something inside of you and then so this
trailer that we chose did and it's
really fun just trying to find the way
to sort of make that into a full if you
have full feature for short film and so
it's been a spin up the process what can
everybody expect from the vélib
they can expect to see um it's gonna be
eerie it's gonna be creepy and it has a
really great theme throughout about
about letting go and accepting traumas
that happened
Jena Malone and I are in it and so bring
back my a girl Hunger Games great yeah I
was hanging out on the set and you guys
are just amazing together yeah that
looks so fun okay thanks yeah hope you
guys like it
so I'm here with Kevin who is producing
the project imagination trailer to film
so what's it like working on this you're
taking somebody else's sort of trailer
and making it into a movie cuz usually
you you go the other way around
yeah right make to make the film first
we make a trailer but you know these
projects we've been where I've been
working with Kenneth and Ron Howard for
the last five years on these projects
and what we've done is taken inspiration
from people that are using them Canon
cameras in the past it had been
photographs but this time it's people
taking 60-second trailers and using that
as the inspiration to make a short like
this so it's it's really fun it's really
inspiring and we get to make something
we're gonna make stuff so it's great
this room is the mother's room of Josh
and Jenna's characters and at a certain
point you will see Josh get upset and
you go to this wall with a sledgehammer
and the magic thing is that's a fake
wall we actually built the wall away
from the real wall so that we can
destroy it
I think a thousand times well yeah you
should have seen it used to have carpet
in here and
and now we're rigging it so it's gonna
flood and do all kinds of gross nasty
stuff you take a look at the magic
happening in the air I have some
problems with my garbage disposals
specialist perfect I think I can
perfectly destroy everything in my house
without any
[Music]